it is that time of year again think 2023
is here and I'm going to be covering the
big announcement coming out of the event
Watson X and its three main components
all on this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
if you checked out any of the keynote
addresses from this year's IBM think
event you've already heard about the
exciting introduction of Watson X
for decades IBM has been at the
Forefront of breakthroughs in Ai and we
know that AI is already driving results
for business
we also believe it is time to place the
power of AI in the hands of all kinds of
AI Builders from data scientists to
developers to Everyday users who have
never written a single line of code
Watson X is IBM's Next Generation AI
platform and it's designed to do just
that
it provides self-service access to high
quality trustworthy data this enables
users to collaborate on a single
platform where they can build and refine
both new generative AI Foundation models
and traditional machine Learning Systems
Watson X helps facilitate the entire
data and AI lifecycle from data
preparation to model development
deployment and monitoring and we believe
it has the potential to scale and
accelerate the impact of the most
advanced AI on every Enterprise
Watson X has three components and I want
to dive a bit deeper into each one
first is Watson x dot AI an AI Studio
designed for the business of today and
tomorrow
watsonnext.ai combines the capabilities
of IBM Watson Studio to build run and
deploy AI based machine learning with
the latest generative AI capabilities
that Leverage The Power of foundation
models
as AI becomes more pervasive businesses
need to feel confident in their models
Watson x.ai provides that essential
level of trust and gives users access to
high quality pre-trained and proprietary
IBM Foundation models for Enterprise
additionally for AI to be truly
transformative as many people as
possible should have access to its
benefits we made sure that Watson x dot
AI is not just for data scientists and
Developers
business users can also access it via an
easy to use interface that responds to
natural language prompts for different
tasks
the second component is watsonx.data
which allows businesses to quickly
connect to data get trusted insights and
reduce data warehouse costs it's a data
store built on an open lake house
architecture and it runs both
on-premises and across multi-cloud
environments optimized for all data
analytics and AI workloads Watson x.data
combines the flexibility of a data lake
with the performance of a data warehouse
helping businesses to scale data
analytics and AI anywhere their data
resides
users can access data through a single
point of entry with a shared metadata
layer across clouds and on-prem
environments
watsonnext.data even comes with built-in
governance security and automation
the third and final component is Watson
x dot governance simply put the more AI
is embedded into daily workflows the
more you need proactive governance
watsonex.governance can help build the
necessary guard rails around AI tools
and the uses of AI it's an automated
data and model lifecycle solution for
creating policies assigning decision
rights and ensuring organizational
accountability for risk and investment
decisions
by providing the mechanisms to help
secure and protect customer privacy and
proactively detect model bias and drift
Watson x.governance helps organizations
meet ethic standards proactively manage
risk and reputation and comply with
regulatory requirements
to sum things up IBM has designed Watson
X to adhere to the core principles of
trust while being as accessible as
possible
a future where trustworthy AI delivers
boost to productivity and enhances
Innovation is not only possible it's
already here let's put AI to work and
make the world work better
to learn more about Watson X and its
components hit the links in the
description of this video
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now